all right what's up guys I think we got
it I think we got it this time my
technical literacy isn't fantastic but
we persevered so thank you for uh
thank you for sticking with it so I'm
going to try to stream on a weekly basis
we'll see how it goes let's see what the
feedback's like I really want to be able
to do these amas and get as many
questions answered as possible while I
take all this extra time to do a lot of
the long form stuff that I've been doing
so that's we're going to focus on so um
as you guys pile up questions I'm going
to sift through I'm going to pick the
ones I think are the most relevant maybe
the ones I can answer the quickest
um real quick got to pay the mortgage so
first of all I got to give a shout out
to uh boost Camp I'm really proud to be
associated with their product if you
haven't checked it out there's just a
ton of programs from Greg Knuckles and
Eric kellems and Cody LeFevre Jeffrey
Verdi Scofield has some stuff up there
now so they're expanding their reach and
it's more than just an app where you
just plug in your numbers and that's
it's a huge learning library and they
have some pretty interesting stuff
coming down the pike I don't think I'm
really at Liberty to say but let's just
say they're looking at making use of
some really exciting new technology that
just came on the scene recently to try
and augment their product so really
excited to be part of that and also if
you guys haven't seen the Barbell
Apparel collaboration I'm really happy
with the way these came out they're kind
of a throwback from uh the original Kong
shirts I had at my gym
and I really like the design really like
the way it came out so also extremely
excited to have Barbell Apparel on board
they've been really good to me and of
course their jeans are extraordinarily
comfortable so that's enough Shilling
for right now
um
Let's uh let's get to answering some
questions
um I had a couple real quick I'm going
to go through from uh patreon I have a
couple old ones that I hadn't really had
a chance to get to and uh once I get
through that I'll get to your guys's
let's see let's see who we got in the
chats today see if I can multitask let's
see if I can read an answer
all right we got some good ones uh two
focuses for mitigating chronic injury
that's a good one I'll get to that one
how are my dogs uh spoiled and uh
actually I don't know if you can see
that's
that's how my dogs live
that's their life right uh what a time
to be live
um
some program questions yeah absolutely
we've got some good ones coming in guys
so start out I want to get to this uh
patreon question really quick uh this
came from uh agum Geo Singh who's a
regular poster on patreon
uh asks what the most important muscle
groups for contact sport athletes like
football basketball Etc it's a good
general question I get a lot of sports
questions and I I wish I had a lot more
um
depth to give I mean that probably
requires a little more specific
consideration with you what position you
play uh What uh your experience is like
what specific issues you're having
generally
we're talking about sports we're talking
about power sports so whatever you do in
the gym
is really just focused on increasing
Force production that that's really it
you generally get stronger in the gym
you generally improve your ability to
squat deadlift press and so on and the
idea is that in the context of your
sport specific application whether it's
soccer football track whatever it is
that as you practice at that extra Force
production is going to be kind of
refined down so that's the idea of
periodization very broad stuff early on
very specific stuff as you go further
along and you want to get those
qualities to transfer over so with
Athletics when you're talking about
um which body parts which movements
basically everything between the kneecap
and the belly button so you're looking
at quads hamstrings glutes hip flexors
abdominals that's it it's really hip
extension knee extension is also
important as you get away from that it's
gonna have a lot more to do with uh the
sport that you're getting ready for so
anything hip dominant anything hip
extension is going to help with just
about all sports contact Sports I mean
midsection is going to be huge because
force transfer is a big thing so the
more you flex your abdominals the more
you squeeze Embrace and you can keep
that torso rigid the more efficiently
you'll be able to transfer Force whether
it's throwing a punch whether it's
tackling somebody whether it's throwing
a shot put because everything comes from
the ground through your knees hips
ankles uh gets expressed through your
torso so the more rigid that is
the better off you're going to be right
it's like would you rather get hit by a
brick or a sponge you know or like a
like a wet sponge you don't want
something that breaks you don't want
something that gives if you have a five
pound bag of sand or a five pound brick
the brick is gonna mess you up a lot
more because it's rigid it transfer all
it transfers all that Force so you want
to get as rigid as possible so that's a
big one uh this first one was a really
good one
uh forehead ass
what's up brother uh what are your top
two focuses for mitigating risk of
chronic injury I mean
my chronic issues
I can talk about those it's a hard thing
to answer generally because there's so
many different reasons you guys are
going to get hurt or deal with stuff as
time goes on my issues have usually been
from being bound overhead pressing
squatting shoulders in in my glutes got
really really tight and I relied on that
for a lot of compression as I would come
down and what happened was I was just
trampolining on the joints without
keeping my basic movement ability really
good without having any type of
flexibility like whatsoever and as time
went on I started to get these overuse
issues and they turned into chronic
issues so my shoulders
like my shoulders
are are toast like they're held together
right now and I have to lift to keep
them feeling good but labrum tears
rotator cuff tears all kinds of [__]
just from being Reckless and not paying
attention movement stuff so I think the
big thing is maintaining balance
as I did more rotator cuff specific work
external rotations uh unstable stuff
with like banded or like bottom-up
kettlebell presses things are unstable
that helped a lot and then rear delt
stuff is really good upper back stuff is
really good and then making sure that I
have some like basic amount of
flexibility and then I'm not using the
weight to like force me into the super
tight compressed area it's a great way
to move weight kind of artificially some
guys have used that but I think that'll
make you bounce so my big thing is don't
plan the stuff that tends to start to
mess you up
uh don't
um ignore basic movement stuff you want
to have some amount of flexibility you
want to have some amount of movement
ability and stay well-rounded and that's
about it and the rest I mean it's going
to be so specific to what you do so um
if you have something that's already
lighting you up
I recommend people stop doing things
that hurt there's enough variety of
stuff you can do the worst thing to do
is nothing
the second worst thing you can do is
keep doing the thing that's been
screwing up we're talking about chronic
issues we're not talking about oh you
got a tweak we're not talking about oh
this this one-off pain set in if you've
been doing something that's been getting
progressively worse don't do that thing
I know some people find controversy in
that and I think that's stupid as time
goes on and you let that injury heal up
you do some other things you find you
find some ground
you can find like an entry point back in
and start building back up and adapting
to that and see how it goes but that's a
very sub that's a very trial and error
individualistic based uh based approach
so I can't really give you a cut and dry
thing you got to see what works really
hard
um let's go down the line uh predictions
for World strongs man I can't even tell
you who's competing right now the more I
compete the less I watch
um so I'm kind of out of the loop as far
as who the big memes are right now I
know Mitch Hooper is running over
everybody
um Trey Mitchell's been doing well
that's about all I know
um
to do
can you do power lifting bodybuilding
absolutely you should you should do that
if you're focused on building muscle and
strength especially as an earlier
athlete
you know it stops specializing if you're
new if you're an intermediate you know
until you're at the point where you're
really trying to take down
big contests big titles
um stop specializing strength is
strength size is size it takes a long
time before you really get those things
to diverge it takes so long you have to
get pretty big you have to get pretty
strong before you're really justified in
focusing just on that thing specificity
is important as you get closer to a show
but in general strength and size is very
much the same thing for newer newer
athletes
man you guys are coming in hot here
straw man comp in June rainey's been
aching from all my carry training any
tips yeah I've dealt with that quite a
bit
um I've had really bad patellar
tendonitis that lingered trying to get
it ready I remember a clash the the year
I did class the first year uh my
patellar tendonitis was insane so first
time I really leaned on ibuprofen for a
prep because I really try not to do that
Ibuprofen and Voltaren uh really held me
on for those workouts where I had
because there was a squat for reps the
one time there's a squat for reps when
knees were just destroyed and I'd look
forward to that for years and then doing
yoke and Farmers on top of it just
because heavy stuff is almost better
because heavy stuff you're controlled
you're even you're you're moving
steadily when it's fast you're trying to
pound your feet just as fast as you can
and that takes a beating I hate yoke
races I hate farmer races because they
light my knees and hips up the absolute
most
um
that's a hard one because you have to
get some work in but you're probably not
going to be best off just sucking up and
going with contest weights uh with a
bunch of anti-inflammatories I would
save until a couple weeks out the
anti-inflammatories to really just get
in what you can but you want to really
limit how much you use that stuff to
keep yourself together
um June I mean you got a couple of
months two months that's actually not
that much time
uh I would just keep frequency down
that's it try to consolidate throughout
the week you know uh anything that uses
your knee squatting carries try to do
them on the same day try to keep it to
once a week the rest of the time focus
on rehabbing those joints limit what you
do in the form of uh of
I'm trying to think like jumping stuff
squatting stuff
um anything that involves pounding your
feet that's really it's just managing
the split I think is the most important
thing and then secondarily is managing
load within that split so you kind of
walk that tightrope of does this hurt
too much is this going to keep me at a
commission for too long it's a really
hard thing to do
[Music]
um
going to work in a village in Africa for
three months and Godspeed
I won't have access to a gym any tips
for not losing too much strength and
size
not really I mean if all of your size
and strength is based on lifting the gym
I mean maintenance is easy but if you
don't do any barbell stuff for three
months like even if you were doing
rigorous calisthenics stuff every day
you're gonna lose some size and strength
just be active I mean the difference
between doing nothing and then being
active somewhat on a regular basis
that's going to be as much as you can
hope for and don't overthink it just get
some daily push-ups lunges sit-ups just
just whatever you can get in
uh
do I still play you you that was a bit
I've never played Yu-Gi-Oh
um
no I was I had my own nerdish Tendencies
but they were never really directed
towards anime or um I don't even know if
yugioh's anime it's like Americanized
anime I never got into the card games
uh
Brian Aldridge programming style all I
know about it is the giant sets I've
watched a few videos of his I know he's
a very athletic dude and it looks like
he keeps that uh keeps that in you
you get strong guys in the context of
of what you've done early on so if
you've always been active if you've
always played a sport and then you throw
barbell training on top of that you do
it for a long time you're going to be
very strong in the context of those
skills and those capacities so if you
are always doing gpp work or if you're a
runner and you're always running or if
you're always doing giant sets or
borderline cardio stuff you can get
strong in the context of doing that if
you couldn't you wouldn't have NFL
players or rugby players that are stupid
strong also being in amazing condition
you just have to make it a priority if
you've been training for a very long
time for um specifically for strength at
the expense of everything else and you
try to transition over there's going to
be some Growing Pains but I would argue
that it's it's worth it
so that that's really all I know about
uh
Brian allzer
he found it to be uh
a lot of work
put things sticking through it would be
better longer yeah I think generally I
mean you don't necessarily have to do it
that way I got in the habit of doing
supersets uh with my main stuff token
volume stuff there's no reason you can't
go do a set of pull-ups or a set of
sit-ups in between so
especially on all the warm-up sets it's
so easy to sneak in volume for other
things and if it can keep your heart
rate up just a little bit it's like why
wouldn't you do that
being strong is really cool guys like
being strong is great it's fantastic
but it sucks if you're not useful
it's a thing that like so many people
don't understand it really sucks if
you're not useful here's the thing that
a lot of people don't know hold on man
it's freezing weird
sorry I keep it like 55 degrees in here
so I need a blanket like a
geriatric this is my uh Nicholas Cage
blanket that my wife got me for my
birthday I think it's pretty fantastic
also keeps you warm
um
yeah here's the thing that a lot of
people don't know is that
when it comes to doing really shitty
endurance stuff if there's ever a point
where you have to be in shape imagine
that the end of the world comes we get
invaded and you have to like grab your
family and just go rock out into the
woods for survival in whatever scenario
you can come up with where you would
have to have endurance your life depends
on it being strong and out of shape
is almost worse than just being out of
shape because when you're strong and out
of shape basically you've conditioned
your body to take the governor off just
completely that's what training is all
those neurological inhibitions you've
convinced your body like hey we don't we
don't need those on we can handle all
this work but if you're in shitty
cardiovascular shape or uh even like
just muscular endurance you're not
conditioned to getting into those later
efforts as uh as the minute goes on
you can dig yourself into a fatigue hole
that is I mean it can borderline be
life-threatening
and I actually knew I knew two guys that
got uh rabdo actually that exact
scenario one of them Abe Ramirez uh rest
in peace he didn't die from that he had
a seizure later on real sad story uh Abe
was a good dude um Regular at my gym
good power lifter and uh but he was a
guy that you know he liked
if you like blasting and he like lifted
really heavy and didn't like doing much
of anything else very talented he had
gone pretty far he did this dumbass
deadlift event that some guy held on
where it was like three guys showed up
for it they're all pretty well known
powerlifters in Southern California and
uh it was like uh
there were two different ones they did
one was like deadlift 500 pounds for a
set of 10 but it was like as many sets
as you could going on for like an hour
like whoever dropped out first or
couldn't finish a set of 10 loss another
one was like a round robin style where
they did singles
um three guys pull 500 pull 500 pull 500
round robin Non-Stop and they ended up
getting into like
70 some reps with 500 pounds
uh the back pump he got was so extreme
that I can't remember if he got
compartment syndrome or not I don't
think he did I think that was a risk but
he did get rhabdo he was
him and one other guy was literally
hospitalized for ABDO and the guy that
didn't get robbedo was the guy that
dropped out earlier because he wasn't
quite as strong as they were so that's
an example I was go to similar with
Crossfit if you're really strong you
just go and try and [__] yourself up out
of the gate you can dig yourself into a
hole so moral of the story kids being
strong is cool but you should strive to
be strong in the context of uh not
ending up in the hospital if you decide
to push it a little too hard one day and
the thing is that guy would have been so
overwhelmingly
he would have been so much better off
he would have handled it so much easier
by simply having something
that is like endurance adjacent into his
uh programming he didn't even have to
specialize if you just had some type of
regular endurance activity
that wouldn't have happened so
that was my story for the day
um
two my take on squat University a hack
who pushes nonsense or a great source
for hitting the stabilizers and tweaking
form
I think he has a lot of really good
stuff but I think like um like so many
people in their profession you know when
you're a hammer everything's a nail he
made a career in his profession because
a lien is I think looking towards the
small stuff that people miss so people
have the mean millimeters of hip shift
there's a difference between trying to
find what's plaguing an individual like
what is your issue that you're dealing
with versus what are recommendations we
can give to
everybody those are two entirely
different things so when he's making
statements that everybody has to have
this picture-perfect form
I find that excessive I I don't agree
however on the other hand the kind of
like you know it just has to be good
enough and you know don't worry about it
if there's some knee cave don't worry
about it if your background you know
it'll be fine the body adapts I think
that gets kind of stupid too there is
kind of a sweet spot and there's a lot
of play in the joints in there but there
is kind of a sweet spot where it's good
enough that you're not really likely to
mess yourself up you can move pretty
efficiently and you can let the
programming do its job
um
without you know having to spend all of
this endless time like refining refining
your stuff but you can go too far on
either route I have
uh looked at one of his books what was
his last one
um rebuilding Milo it was really good
there was some great stuff in there that
I used on myself that I couldn't find
anywhere else so if you're a person
who's having a chronic issue those
resources are invaluable because it
might be these things that you looked
past that you weren't really aware of it
might be those things that are
contributing and it might not it might
be something else might be load
management very well might be some some
people are intolerant to frequency some
people need more time to build a
tolerance to the type of work they're
doing some people got too strong too
quick there's a lot of reasons you'll
have these issues but um you have to be
able to trust that people can sift
through all of them Implement some trial
and error and get to the root of it
you're not going to have the key to all
of your problems and then Instagram me
you're just not so I don't
I don't fault him too much I I mean I
know he said some things in in kind of
an absolute as tone he plays into it but
I think the the culture at large has to
be responsible for taking all of this
and kind of assimilating it into a
really useful way that gets a good
result uh any thoughts on one-armed
barbellifts uh no
I have no thoughts about those none
pulling exercise with a bad bicep yeah I
got I lost my bicep a couple years ago
too
um depends how new it was a year ago and
it hasn't recovered fully I mean I
didn't get surgery on mine but mine was
recovered in a couple of weeks I mean I
took bpc157 for it
um
the 10 didn't regrew in like three weeks
I did a straw man contest four weeks
after tearing it
uh
results May Vary I'm not telling you all
to go load up on bpc but um
I don't know it's hard that's super
individual
as with all injuries you know
um I do regular barbell stuff I never
switched I never compensated so do what
you can find an entry point move forward
and I don't know what what you mean by
bad if it hurts or if it's just weak
because my bicep I mean I can do pretty
well on Stone loads and barbell rows and
stuff but I feel it on pull-ups it's
probably when I do curls like dumbbell
curls probably still about 15 weaker
than the other side and probably always
will be so um I would just use bilateral
movements and just train it as normal
that's what I that's what it's what I
actually do do so
forward
I wish I could answer all of these but
man
wolf Larson thank you super chats forgot
about the super jets
classical periodization unnecessary for
recreational lifters is do you pee
enough
oh man don't get me started on
periodization it's gonna be like another
Dave Tate talk where uh we we talk so
much about all of the theory and all of
the potential applications
um without giving anything too
actionable it's my biggest regret about
that uh interview when I look back at it
is
and I love that type of conversation I
find it very stimulating
but um I regret not giving anything more
concrete really tethering that stuff
back down to earth this is one of those
questions it's really hard to nail down
because there's so many different
circumstances where it can go one or the
other for the most part a full classical
periodization I think of a macro cycle
like starting
before a contest like 16 weeks 20 weeks
out and then going through all the the
mesocycles or all the phases all the all
the way down to a contest taper to a max
out yeah most recreational lifters do
not need to do that the whole point of
Base strength when I wrote it which I
have to rewrite it because
I don't think this point got expressed
as well as it should be
the whole point of Base strength was
that that periodization is
it's not required it doesn't have to be
so specific if you want to go that route
it'll be very productive I recommend the
long-term lifters do that if you're a
serious lifter I recommend eventually
you get comfortable with that form of
training but the average Recreation
lifter you just seen a minimum amount of
variation you do need some so it helps
you can look at it through that context
of volume over here strength over here
less specific more specific it's a back
and forth so I took something relatively
complex and just kind of broke it down
to what I thought the minimum amount of
complexity needed to get the desired
result for a recreation lifter and
that's it but even so
most of the progressions somebody might
run most of the types of training
somebody might run you might be able to
run it for a very very long time without
necessarily having to swap it so I think
that's important knowing what to switch
up when it does get stale but guys if
you're doing it and it works
keep doing it the first I get so many
people that are like man I love this
program around this program it was great
I'm going to do this next program you
put out next and I always have to say
like well how are your results you're
like well it was good you know I'm 10
stronger I added this much on all my
lips it's like do it again just do it
again you're a new lifter you're not
getting ready for me you're just trying
to build a foundation of strength this
thing work do it again
uh it's gonna be a while when you're new
or even when you're intermediate if
something is is paying off before you
really have to switch now if you're a
contest focused athlete
different story eventually you do have
to get into contest prep and there's a
lot of guys that have they're just
general training and then they have
their taper there's a lot of guys that
train that way too so many ways to skin
a cat and I wish I could give you uh the
one size fits all
um
do something like classical
periodization if you really are
OCD and you want a program that's laid
out three months in advance
and you want to know exactly what to do
if you have the the temperament the
personality type to do that start to
finish and you're not going to get three
weeks into the hypertrophy phase and say
this is [__] [__] jump do
something else then go that route
but most recreational lifters I would
recommend something simpler I recommend
a simpler progression something that
does allow for more effort early on
something that does allow for more
variety of thresholds to be trained more
consistently I am inclined to think that
would be more beneficial to more lifters
uh
what nerd stuff did I get into
man uh comic books was the big one
um I drew a lot as a kid uh I read a lot
my dad was really into my dad was a
psychiatrist
so there was a lot of stuff from like a
psychology standpoint that we were
talking about but he had this like weird
kind of side hobby for like
pop culture science so things about you
know whether it was like quantum physics
or engineering or evolutionary biology
so we would have a lot of talks about
that so I had a lot of books um
on all of that stuff that I dove into
when I was pretty young and I really
like those classes the most when I was
in college I was in college for like 10
years and I don't even think I have an
Associates to show for it because I kept
bouncing around but the hard science
classes I love the absolute most those
were the most useful those are the ones
that I still lean on when it comes to
critical thinking or analyzing things
those are the Sanders that were set but
outright nerd stuff is comic book
superhero stuff I've seen every Marvel
movie except like the last two years
worth once I realized how bad the Disney
plus plus shows were I
tapped out and uh I had every Spawn
comic ever made spawn was my [__] when I
was like 10 years old
um looking back on it stories were
horrible the writing was horrible but I
love the artwork and how edgy was
there's nothing like edgy 90s comic
books
everything was extreme everything was
extra everything was over muscled and I
always say when I'm looking at
when I'm looking at
uh things like body positivity when I'm
looking at uh and this has been going on
since I was a kid I remember hearing
about eating disorders because at the
time everything was like heroin Chic so
women were looking at like Kate Moss
women were looking at these models that
had no me no ass they were all 98 pounds
and probably had you know early onset
osteoporosis and it was brutal it was a
brutal field to be in and it was
completely
um
I mean it chewed people up because the
expectations were there the beauty
standards didn't give so you take young
girls and expose them to all this stuff
and they're like holy hell like how do
you meet this standard if you're a girl
and you're over five foot four how do
you meet that standard if you do have
hips if you do have legs in that how do
you meet that standard so you get that
um fixation on pop culture and at least
eating disorders and self-esteems
self-esteem stuff and so on and I would
hear that
and they would you know say like oh if
you scale Barbie to life size should be
like seven and a half feet tall I hear
that and I'm like looking at all of my
action figures
and I remember I had one of uh
of uh what strong guy that was his name
strong guy and a huge body in his head
was like that big you look at the
proportions you're looking at like a Rob
I feel coming if you look at some of the
ridiculous [__] that was written and
it's like
do we all is this the source of all of
it is this like the insecurity in the
body dysmorphia that and we just never
pinpointed it we never thought about it
we just took it as normal went about our
lives and became hobbyist lifters trying
to chase these uh unattainable standards
I don't know
anyways that's that's my uh that's my
connection to my nerd history
I guess oh my God there's so many guys
Marvel is failing don't get me started
man I really wish I had more time to put
into that other channel because I really
would like to do like a pop culture
movie review uh lean but I haven't
figured out how to how to write
um a script in less than like five days
when I do I think I'll put more time
into that but uh yeah don't get me
started I don't even care about about
the woke stuff like I don't even care
ideologically every good piece of art is
going to have pieces of the person that
made it in it I I don't care if it
challenges what I think or if it has a
different leaner perspective make it
good just make it good
don't use it as a human shield to
insulate your product from criticisms
make it good
she there what's up buddy
man I got inspiration from you all those
open Office uh live streams you've been
doing I'm like I gotta step it up I
gotta make myself more accessible
[Music]
Dan Henderson you skip my question why
because there's 500 questions on here
and I can't get to them all
Kong is very fun and refreshing
Hugh new member thanks buddy
here's a question I have for you guys
any of you that are members because I'm
trying to balance uh my engagement with
all of you guys I'm going to do this a
lot more often but um
I'm trying to figure out how to make the
most of the YouTube memberships I have
patreon I'm pretty active on there I
post weekly threads uh q and A's up
there
um I'll put post training footage and
what's going on and I engage a bit more
there
um if any of you guys have ideas or
things you've
experience on other channels that you're
members of if you have any ideas for
that help me out because I want to be
able to give as much as I can
what's my next video going to be about
this is a uh one that I've been talking
about I've been writing for way too long
it's going to be kind of like the bench
video that I did a couple months ago it
was the first long-form video that was
hyper edited that did very well and
that's what I'm trying to move my con my
content to I want it to be more like
video essay type stuff it's just so much
more rigorous and I do everything myself
all of my editing I do myself all the
writing all the filming it's
exhausting in this weird kind of
psychological way I'm not used to giving
this much creative effort I can sit in
front of a camera and talk for hours
about this [__] nobody's gonna watch
that so I gotta invest time into
refining these other skills so I'm going
to do that for uh for squatting and then
I have some ideas I gotta go back to
some programming videos I've been away
from uh kind of and I don't mean
programming like program reviews
breaking down other popular programs I
mean giving like basic advice on how to
run through training in a reliable
predictable way for the average trainee
given X Y or Z so I got to go back to
that
um so squatting basically had a squat
for no gains that's the that's the thing
Kong is very fun and refreshing thanks
buddy that's kind of what it was meant
to be refreshing
it's uh I mean it is a hypertrophy
program but there's a reason it's just
four weeks of no barbell stuff with a
lot of high rep isolation stuff it is to
clear out when you get kind of burnt out
from all the beat down so especially
going into uh a contest prep or just the
beat down of barbell stuff heavy over
and over and over if all you get is that
four week little period to do some
higher up stuff remember what it's like
to catch a pump then you can carry that
into the accessory work because you get
some momentum there as you start to
reintroduce barbell stuff it's a good
it's
it's not meant to be like this is going
to be the best program you've ever run
that you should run for the rest of your
life I wrote it as a changeup
if I tried chat GPT to support my
training uh no I've I've seen people
type some stuff in I know you can ask it
for training advice whatever not to
support my training I've [__] around
with it for so many other things I'm
trying to use it to help me write
content faster because the fact is AI
can now write rough drafts better than I
can and it takes a fraction of a it
takes a fraction of the time
is just so awesome what they've been
able to do
and actually I did a an interview a
couple of days ago actually with a guy
who's a professor of computer science at
UC Berkeley and he's writing a book and
we did like an hour and a half long
interview on one of his chapters it's
about
just evaluating science like how to
apply it in these practical capacities
what the shortcomings are and when
science kind of becomes this thing that
we put up on a pedestal and people are
engaging for the sake of it not for the
sake of truth whatever we had a real and
I'm gonna pull some pieces of that and
put it up but um they use a computer
science major we actually went into or
sorry computer science Professor we
actually went into the the weeds with AI
stuff for a little bit super fascinating
but I'm uh I'm trying to use that a
little bit better or a little I'm trying
to use that a little bit more to make my
content production a little bit faster
get the rough draft out streamline all
this [__] and then I can come in and
punch it up instead of burning myself
out trying to
string together coherent senses when I'm
under caffeinated
uh
Hugh just happy to support you on
YouTube man that's the spirit you guys
are something else
psychological aspect of missing a lot of
time and making a comeback for rotator
cuff surgery I could write five books on
that best thing I ever learned 100 best
thing I ever learned is that it doesn't
matter how much time you take off
doesn't matter how much progress you
lose first time I figured out that you
don't just keep the strength you got I
was like mortified and then it's like I
gotta I got a White Knuckle that I gotta
keep my names you know you can take a
ton of time off you can lose 50 of your
strength I broke my ankle
broke my foot completely off of the bone
have a plate and 12 screws in my leg and
uh that is the story behind why I wear
only lifters now where I did it for 10
years before that but I could squat 135
when I came back and I got such
debilitating pain from doing it on the
way back I thought I'd never lift again
it took about four months of training
before I hit an all-time PR after that
and I use that now I actually use that
to clear out when things hurt when
psychologically I'm burnt out in between
contests I know what my time to get back
to normal is six or eight weeks to get
back to normal
another six or eight weeks of hard ass
training to get in PR territory
do not kill yourself
trying to hold on to all your games take
time off when you need it come backs are
fast as long as you do them right just
know that when you come back you're not
going to be lifting heavy that's fine
come back start at 50 of what you're
able to do go on a linear progression
even for more advanced lifters LPS are
extremely useful for comebacks they're
not sustainable once you get back into
the weeds
but they're extremely useful so uh take
your time let your body tell you when
you're you're good to come back
CK all right I don't know what SEK is
I don't know if that's a lot or a little
but thank you either way brother
Seether the longer I've spent and
strongly on the more I have come to
agree with your belief that push press
should be the base lift of strongman
you're selecting the most challenging
option possible as your base lift
I always show you sign up for will be
equal in difficulty or easier to gain
good momentum that being said scaling
that to using strict
base overhead movement uh seems just
lead to people being drastically
underskilled at dip and drive mechanics
and probably over Awards a layback
pattern if heavier strict presses is the
feedback loop as improving as an
overhead athlete yeah and I've always
prioritized it as um
as the thing that carries over to the
most things as well
so the the common theme is that people
jump into a jerk because especially when
you're newer when you're less developed
a push jerk the gap between what you can
do in a push press and a jerk for a lot
of like beginning athletes this is true
for a lot of women as well who usually
have a bigger disparity between their
lower and upper body strength at the
start at least
they can just do so much more in a jerk
in a shorter period of time and then
they're like well that's what I got to
do and then you get some people become
very good at the jerk who have these
deficiencies in their press and I know a
lot of people who played into that to
the point where if they have a barbell
or even a log on relatively flat ground
they can do all right but once you get
into like uh circus dumbbell territory
on objects
AG presses block presses so on they uh
they lose the ability to fall back on
that and it becomes a problem push press
just carries over to everything I got
really good at Pusher here I was 20 or
21 and I did a pusher out of Iraq with
365 for a double
and that was long before Peds and that's
when I first thought like oh I can get
good at this now that was my pet lift I
have short arms my little docks and
limbs barbarelli clears over my head I
had some advantages that reinforced my
uh My Success there but that's when I
was like oh I could potentially be very
good at this a couple years later I made
a conscious decision to never push jerk
again and to just push press because I
kept getting my ass kicked in log
presses I kept losing my balance when I
was looking at high ceilings or blue sky
when I was a log pressing outside I kept
missing the lockout on odd presses and
it was pissing me off and it took a
couple years before I push pressed 365
but by the time I got to that point
I actually couldn't push your 365
anymore just the skill decade potential
is up but my actual skill just dropped
but it didn't matter because I was
infinitely better at overhead pressing
than anything else so um so yeah that
skill uh reinforcement is very very big
but also you still get the lockout you
still get enough mechanical tension on
the upper body that a push press can
still develop the shoulders and triceps
in a very useful way how often do I take
q and A's on patreon I just started
doing
um I just started doing weekly so every
Friday or Saturday I post a weekly
thread
um I leave it up to people to put um
videos if they want form checks
some guys and I try to answer everything
some guys will come in with three posts
worth of uh their weekly thoughts
um but I try to give everybody a touch I
try to give something meaningful to
everybody so if you're on my patreon
I I really try to do uh the best service
I can there
what degree of backgrounding is
acceptable all deadlifting oh my God you
guys are trying to start a war here uh
it varies from person to person because
there's the answer I can give to the
population at large if I was coaching a
bunch of people what I would allow for
but then there's individuals I know some
outliers I know some freeze Andrew mock
is a great example buddy of mine he's
six foot three and he competes as a 231
strongman very lanky also has no body
fat on him loves to take his shirt off
Andrew has steel cable Erectors he has
the ugliest deadlift form I've ever seen
in my life has never had a back injury
and when I tried to take him out of him
take him out of that setup he went so
far back that it became obvious that
that extra ground to make up wasn't
worth it it would take too long so it
didn't seem to be a problem so he
actually I mean imagine how you would
set up if you were at the bottom of a
stiff leg deadlift and you were trying
to stretch your hamstrings as much as
you could before pulling that's how he
pulls and he does so with his back in a
complete round consequently fantastic
Stone loader great at Mass wrestling
anything where his back has to be
rounded he's really good however he's an
outlier I guarantee if you had a hundred
young kids train like that
a big chunk of them would have issues
moving forward a lot of them might get
really strong records but a big chunk of
them would have problems so
while there is playing the joints there
is individuality that's going to change
from person to person I still believe
there's also a standard there's some
other sport or discipline in the world
where you just leave it up to what feels
good to the to the athlete there has to
be a standard there's no successful
coaching organization that has put out a
lot of good lifters that would just say
you know however you get it up is fine
so you can round as long as one I would
say the upper back is fine if you're
rounding in your lumbar spine I would
look into that I think eventually that
can potentially become a problem more
for some people than others maybe but
still not a great thing to do and I
would also say that the efficiency of
the deadlift is also more important
that's why I harp on the technique even
if you can get away with it it is a less
efficient way to pull period full stop
the more rigid your midsection is the
more when you pull up your hamstrings
and your glutes the more uh the spine
maintains posture the more efficient
you're going to be on your pole period
if you're like a spa lunge if you're
like a just a a wet noodle and you just
give like a like a telephone pole in a
hurricane like you don't want that
that's not officially you wouldn't you
wouldn't allow that in any other lift or
in any other sport why would you allow
with deadlifts it's just because it's
what a way to not scare people off of
deadlifting I find that ridiculous
um
direct AB oblique lower back training
for hypertrophy and strength with the
hope to carry over to compound lifts
um it's only going to really carry over
if you're weak so if you have a big
problem with your midsection which I did
for a long time that's why I got injured
in my low back so many times I had a
dozen injuries over 10 years each one
put me out for six weeks or longer
made it hard to put my socks on made
life miserable it wasn't until I figured
out how to brace and how to get tight
through my midsection
that I could actually
get any ground on my deadlift without
getting sidelined part of that was
direct ab work
part of it was also um
bracing so
you see Ed Cohen doing like uh barbell
holds like suitcase holds with a barbell
like that's a good one I think
isometrics heavy offloaded stuff
um stuff like
um anti-rotation movements are great
doesn't necessarily have to be like
sit-ups or anything although anything
that gets your abs stronger is going to
help with that now if you don't have a
direct weakness I wouldn't expect to
notice Direct carryover I don't think
we're selling uh
I don't know how to pronounce your name
those uh those letters don't go together
blanchukes I don't know uh thank you for
your donation brother what is your
opinion on overhead press to improve my
bench does it seem to help my bench
bench 362 overhead presses 220.
um God I'm trying to do the math off top
of my head
uh first of all overhead press meaning
strict or push press
um that makes a big difference if you
can only push press 220 and you got a
362 bench that is a uh a pretty big
disparity there
pretty big disparity is it Alex Leonidas
I think at a 400 bench I think his best
strict press was about 220 225 I think
um there's probably room to build up
your overhead press a little bit but um
it's not always going to be one-to-one
depends where your weakness is depends
um how you bench pressed depends what
your leverages are a lot of things go
into it so in general strongman know in
general that
benching usually doesn't correlate to
overhead pressing unless you had like
really [__] triceps or something and you
did like a bunch of floor pressing and I
fixed that weakness but in general you
can go bench getting over uh get a bench
PR your overhead isn't going to do much
however a lot of benchers find that when
they focus on overhead pressing and that
goes up that the front delts getting
stronger actually helps with that
um the question is how you balance it if
you're on a barbell specific program
that's most your work then yeah dedicate
some time to overhead pressing doesn't
have to be
the same split it can be lighter you can
use variations you could use behind the
neck you can use wider grip you can use
different bars there's a bunch of
different things you can do if you're
using compound movement specifically in
your training to make it sustainable
it's not necessarily like you have to
well I bench exactly the way that I over
a press you can give one priority for
strict stuff
sorry not for sure so for uh accessory
stuff if you uh do a wide variety of
accessory work then it's super easy to
get it in you can specialize on benching
and you can do things like front I love
front raises front razors are great you
do lateral raises you can do dips
there's a bunch of exercises you can do
as long as the shoulders are getting hit
that's the important thing
dude take some inventory you know if you
have a 362 bench Can you do strict front
raises with 50 pound dumbbells if you
can't shoulder's probably got to get a
bit Gotta Get A Little Bit Stronger so
something to keep in mind
um
oh yeah she either answered this too I
remember that when you had your open
Office I I asked this question if you
bench with a narrow narrower grip with a
greater amount of horizontal bar travel
you might see a greater amount of
carryover from overhead work so that's
like where an overhead is like if I can
turn to the side here
um
like a front race
and I've seen this demonstrated by some
big Ventures I've heard cows when I talk
about this Roy Walker talked about this
where when you hit low
and you come back when you do that curve
back over your face that is a bunch of
front delt right there so when you get
that action
um that extra strength gives you better
control as you manage to get that sucker
back over your face
um
so you are likely to lose strength on
barbell exercises on the Kong program
um
if you're the person that is focusing on
your your max strength at every week
yes but that's not how you should
approach programming on something that
features distinct mesocycles because
that's a that's a main feature of
periodization in a long year-long plan
there will be times in your training
where your max strength is not at an
all-time high that's what peaking is you
have to be fatigued enough to grow
fatigue masks Fitness if you're training
hard enough to grow you're not going to
be fresh enough to be peaked that
Dynamic exists also when you're training
on different things prioritizing
different things you will not always be
anybody who says they're peaking all the
time is full of [__] that means they
don't know what peaking means in the
hardest training you're doing or the one
that you might need the most because
it's Shoring up the biggest weaknesses
you have to widen that base out so you
can actually have a higher strength
potential when you're doing that your
max strength probably going to be down a
little bit it comes back quick that's
why we do these block type approaches to
build qualities over here and Pay It
Forward down the line four weeks is not
enough to seriously detrain your lips
especially in uh in the face of regular
activity so um
to do
uh my camera is overheating guys so I
think I got a couple minutes left here
thanks so much for stopping in I'm gonna
see if I got a
let's get one more good one let's leave
on a good note
saw Paul Mauser was in here earlier when
I had my botched
if you're still here what's up Paul
sorry I had technical technical
difficulties I wanted to know exactly
what you meant when you said what the
hell
more place on demand for a second I
thought I had a heavy hitter in here
more plates no dates that's a good one
that's true more plates now dates that's
absolutely true uh
if you're skilled at dating it doesn't
matter how big or how strong you are all
that time the gym is times not spent
talking to females
or if you're a female it's different for
females I'm not getting into that
um but yeah it's a good way to dig into
being an anti-social goober and that's
exactly what I did and that's why I'm
here right now
is incline barbell press truly The Sweet
Spot in the middle of bench and overhead
I would actually say no or at least not
for everybody I know some people that
had a ton of success with incline they
really like it for an accessory to
overhead
um I almost say it as like the worst of
Both Worlds
that's just you know that's not a very
good answer
um I know uh Lori Walker's a good
example he trained in my uh
in my gym in Redlands for a couple
months he's a big gym Hopper he's in
Austin now actually shockingly enough he
was trying to get his social media going
so he was like touring around all the
gyms but I got a couple bench workouts
with him and it this guy um
was like a 675 Venture and incline
benching was like his number one thing
he loved it it would piss off all the
other powerlifters because they were
like dude do an actual specific prep
stop incline benching you might hit that
700 bench I watched this guy in a meet
get 700 no shirt uh basically a flat
back
pretty narrow grip three quarters of the
way to lock out it was impressive and he
swore by incline pressing that seems
like a very individual thing that
doesn't seem like something that would
necessarily carry over but then again if
you love incline benching and you get it
really really good overall you're
benching it's going to go up it's just a
matter of where you switch gears to be
really really specific so we're always
going back and forth between general or
specific
um
advice for extra exercise for beginner
programs like grade school
no those are hard to screw up their
recommendations are good I don't know
why you would want to tweak them they're
supposed to be simple programs don't
overthink it
based
oh man
I've been watching a lot of streaming
lately that was also part of the
inspiration for this I was the guy um
10 years ago they couldn't understand
why kids were watching videos of people
playing video games instead of playing
the video games in fact why the [__]
weren't they just playing outside now uh
we don't have cable but we have a
YouTube app on our TV so I just I watch
it and see them on YouTube we started
watching streaming
so I'm clocking the steady decline of my
psychology and my Social Security social
skills as time goes on I also find
myself using the lingo that uh would
have angered me not that long ago and
now it's like well this makes sense
when I saw somebody say based in
response to something I said that
genuinely made me happy
this is where I'm at my life
when Leroy was working with Josh Brian
it seemed that a big part of the reason
he inclined was from
low backs pain on flatbeds Josh had to
have him doing feed elevated work mostly
huh that's interesting and he would do a
lot of uh a lot of feed elevated work
you absolutely would do that uh yeah
he's a guy his hips were so goddamn
tight he had a hard time getting his
feet down to the ground
um
and because of that because he has such
a non-specific style he had like did the
weird thumbs out thing and he grip real
close together
um and he would take you straight down
with like his elbows flared out flat
back no Mobility it's like the
anti-power lifting setup and he just got
strong as [__]
um
yeah that makes perfect sense and if
that's how it started and he just got
really strong that way it's like oh well
now I can Mitch more yeah more Trend
more men that's going on a t-shirt Jesus
Christ keep them coming guys I need to
up my merch King my uh merch game
um t-shirt I'm wearing right now oh [__]
I'm supposed to be wearing my Barbell
Apparel stuff don't tell them don't tell
this Black Rifle coffee when we moved to
Texas I had exactly uh five contest
shirts
and that was it so uh I had to throw all
of them out because we moved in my truck
and that's all we took when we drove
from California so one of the first
places I bought clothes was at the Black
Rifle Coffee in San Antonio and I went
in and bought like nine shirts and this
was one of them so
I know people that I can't wear this
[__] online without people giving some
Black Rifle commentary it's either
people that see them as being like uh
Uber conservative nut jobs because it's
all like military and guns whatever or
the conservative people that think
they're like actually liberal Cuts
because some of the other stuff they
said I don't care guys I don't uh I
don't wear clothing as a reflection of
political ideology their coffee tastes
good and they were close and I needed a
t-shirt
I agree with Pete rubish suggestion to
do weighted back extensions absolutely
absolutely it's a great exercise and so
one thing I programmed and nobody ever
does super great way to hit your
posterior chain in a way that doesn't
blow out your recovery it's like the way
I recommend rdls it's like a
bodybuilding version of a deadlift
doesn't [__] with your CNS the same way
but it builds those muscles back
extension is at times 10. you just have
to do more reps to make it effective
just because of the nature of the
movement people hate doing reps because
it's uncomfortable if you can commit to
doing 8 to 15 reps with heavy ass weight
for really really hard work and progress
that the way you progress everything
else your your posterior is just going
to be on another level 45 or horizontal
doesn't matter pick one doesn't matter
don't sweat the details pick one and get
good at it you don't have to do every
exercise under the sun
yeah she either knows bro she either
knows she either what's up with you man
how are you doing today what do you got
on the uh
what do you got coming up you got a meat
coming up any more strong man stuff
I'm fizzy I'm literally waiting for my
camera to die right now it's overheating
so
if the uh circuitry doesn't cook we'll
keep this going as long as we can
lower reps four to six on RDL good
absolutely but not all the time people
avoid tens and Toes because they hate
them fantastic for hypertrophy most
people need bigger hams bigger ass
bigger Erectors uh tens and twelves on
rdls at some point if you want to go
heavy to your fives do a back offset
amrap 10 to 12. something hard something
with weight don't be this 500 pound
deadlifter that does our deals with 135
get some weight get some weight on there
I have to send my clients videos of some
of my former female lifters who are
doing rdls with like 275 to shame them
God help me I'll put glue Bridges be
like I did glue Bridges with 225. it's
like yeah girls using 405 you know 120
pound non-competitive like physique
girls so it's like have some pride guys
either do these exercises or don't if
you hate them and you're like it's hard
I don't want to do it don't do it but um
this stuff is Magic as long as you treat
it well
all of my stuff about recovery and
programming is based around the fact
that the big lifts are hard to recover
from when you stumble across an exercise
that builds you well and it's easy to
recover from spam that [__] as much as
you can spam it over and over and over
because there's there's no wrong shut up
cash okay over there there's no wrong
answers with those exercises that's why
bodybuilders can train recklessly they
don't need programs the nature of the
exercise doesn't require you to walk a
tightrope
trying to get clearances no equipment
High bar pause is my current training
objective then you're gonna pick a show
I don't
I'm out of the loop Clarence Kennedy no
equipment High bar pause
so what number is that you're just
trying to beat his number or you're just
trying to set a new number altogether
trying to set the bar up
no top 10 Christmas movies because I'm a
lazy piece of [__] because I'm trying to
focus on this channel like you're
finding distractions I'm like I'm gonna
start another Channel I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a course I'm gonna write
another book I'll do 10 different things
this year is going to be about this
channel
um
the movie stuff kills me because that's
what most of my shower rants are above
because I'm a nerd I'm a comic book fan
I'm a pop culture fan but I'm also a
huge movie fan so when those two things
conflict I just go off uh top 10
Christmas movies I'm gonna get into that
um
The Family Man Nick Cage is probably
number one
uh that movie turns me into a
Sentimental [__]
I make Laura watch that every year also
like just friends with Ryan Reynolds
um and Amy Smart Amy Smart whatever
happened to her
Vacation movies are also up there
if you're not subscribed to shether what
have you been doing I know
I know totally by the way I told Dave to
check you out because Dave loves talking
nerding out about stuff and when I
thought about somebody like I need to be
sold because I'm not jacked I'm not that
strong especially right now I'm not that
accomplished
so it's like a bigger barrier and I'm
like who's really [__] strong that
can talk to Dave T for four hours
straight
and like just Enlighten everybody in the
room
but Sam Bro
so all of you if you're a fan of Sam go
uh go message Dave and tell him he needs
to get Sam on the show
increasing weight on RDL makes your low
you feel your lower back one of your
hamstrings one of the reasons you need
to do it not necessarily increase weight
it's just as good of a bracing exercise
as it is a hamstring developer so use it
as a bracing exercise and if that's
where you're struggling keep the weight
below that point focus on imagine that
at any given time some YouTube prankster
is going to come soccer kick you in the
ribs while you're doing it make your
face turn red start sweating get veins
popping out of your skull when you do it
make the lighter weight work for you if
you have to
but have that be the limiting factor
when you're selecting weight do I feel
that my back or my braced and my rock
[__] solid it's not sexy but it works
better than anything you can do
675 High bar pause all right
oh you got that in you I saw your front
I feel like I feel like you could front
squat that in the near future
recommendations for getting better
astronomy and conditioning do strong man
events that's that's really it
um
I mean you can do intervals I think
that's as complex as you should get like
imams you can do that with just about
any any strong man thing
um so that's pretty easy just simple
interval stuff or just do uh do runs
don't shy away from medleys don't shy
away from Tire flips don't shy away from
high rep Stone loading or keg loading
practice you know ground to shoulder as
long as you're regularly doing the
movements your conditioning will be
great
you just got to put them in and
look there's a reason
that when you when you saw like the West
Side guys doing gpp you saw them doing
drags and hustle carries
it's fantastic conditioning where it can
build your capacity up it has a lot of
value regardless of whether or not you
compete
and take it seriously you have to take
it seriously don't just go from a
Implement to implement like just getting
your toe in the water you know it's an
Implement it's meant to be strenuous and
again it's another thing you can strain
yourself on those movements because
they're so varied and different you're
inefficient at them it's hard to burn
yourself out I'm a strong man stuff
until you really get a lot more advanced
all right my voice is getting hoarse I'm
at an hour good
that's what I wanted to do I'm like can
I talk for an hour straight you all know
I can talk for an hour straight thanks
guys for stopping by uh today's Saturday
I'm probably gonna experiment see what
days this works best for
I don't uh I don't know if a weekend or
like a Wednesday or a Thursday would be
better I'll experiment I'm gonna try and
make this a weekly thing
um if you guys haven't if you want to
get a hold of me if there's a question
you asked here I didn't get to patreon
is the easiest way to get to me
um or actually the the YouTube
memberships thank you to the people that
signed up today to support that's huge
and I'd say it routinely I know it gets
old but sincerely like that type of
support it's the only reason I was able
to do this full-time is the only reason
my content production's gotten better
it's the only reason that I've been able
to put out content more frequently
because trying to do this well like
working at a restaurant that [__] was
going nowhere fast so um seriously I
appreciate all of that
um take care guys until next time this
is Romney we'll see ya
foreign